hello all and welcome my name is
prestige and I welcome you to the first
of hopefully many mod spotlight showcase
thing is so let's get started and let's
get started by Mike let's get started by
will get a time when it's all okay yeah
so you've got some ultima sphere Oh
kapowee kaboom blammo level food splats
flappy fly yeah boom floppy flower and I
look a little more right down fire
alright so I'm going to be showing you a
little more in depth of the stuff stuff
that I should I showed you and some more
stops so I don't wait let's get let's
get let's get to it but let's start off
with the fireball highball oh wait I
said let's ever for the fibro show ye ok
so this mod implements three new things
one khlo trail mix and to our weapons
well those are the only items that
implements and uh yeah you can eat the
trail mix and it gives you speed a
little boo bad naughty a little
catchphrase thingies but like sounds
when you hit some animals and it gives
you superpowers when you're hitting an
animal because see that was it to hit
it's a damned soul so some strength some
speed and you can also survive falls
let's go to game mode one you can
survive a greater falls when you have it
activated ah just be gone like this and
yea there is a little animation like a
clouds
when you die that should be good oh no
don't do that there should be a little
nervous this fall will kill me normally
but we're going to get us some trail mix
and we'll be okay wow I was running up
bhupinder dirt dirt also you can see
it's a cumulative it's not like a normal
potion we're just only 20 like 20
seconds and no more than that and if you
have over a minutes and you have nothing
in your hand you click the middle button
you shoot fireballs so that's cool and
let's go woohoo and you see that would
have totally killed me and I'm fine oh
it's got some speed and also i'm gonna
show you something we do the piece you
saw that the pigs before flu well hey
i'm probably die from this but uh pull
up bigger you see we get extra time when
we give him more stuff and this is an
awesome of the trap because he can fly a
pic earner dodge purga dodge and yeah
you can tease of propelled by his fox
and that's cool and i'm gonna get off
him so bail and he's going to keep going
for a little bit and he is going to blow
up so i'll show you the crafting recipes
for the stuff now you see there are the
teeth mpb launcher and the neon pig
launcher so i'll show you that soon nuff
Oh trimix so for trail mix you need
glowstone gun powder sugar and read some
you don't need them in any specific
order just for them to be in a square
and you get for comics so yeah so the
next thing we got uh the TMP be launcher
so we're gonna wanna get all of this
stuff and we're gonna want to craft so
you need for iron one gun powder a
dispenser a piston a piece of pink Diana
piece of sitting and you get the TM PP
launcher now you see the MPP launcher
let's get some well that looks so
freaking bulky amazing like it's like a
rocket oh so good it is so you start
with it unloaded now you're about to see
what it takes his ammo come here it
takes pigs you just hold right click and
it sucks in pigs and you get all the
good pig is and the way for you shoot
them out and if you have some trail mix
in your inventory shoot it gives one of
them to it and the pigs jump around and
they blew up and bull they fly around in
the blow boom boom boom boom so it's
pretty cool now we get over here and
actually I'm going to head into game
mode 1 we don't want to do this with mom
so x set 0 can go to 0 there we go now
we're going to throw the TT MP launcher
back in the chest here and that's plate
load now we got the neon pig launcher so
we're going to grab all of our stuff now
this one is a little bit more expensive
but it's totally worth it now I think
these have to be in a certain order and
I don't remember their order all so
hopefully they don't actually have to be
in order because that would suck so you
need a glass pane magenta dyland I like
blue dye dandelion yellow rose red and
orange Diana diamond and a TMP p
launcher okay they do need to be in the
right order so one second i'll be back
and I'll give you the order okay we're
back and it turns out that you need a
mid purple dye not magenta die and then
do need to be in this order so red
orange yellow purple light blue lime and
diamond m TT MPP launcher and glass
paint and that gives you the neon pig
launcher and also quick note be careful
when you're launching these pigs because
they might come and though you
are so we're going to need some more
pays out there light blue okay we need
some more pigs so we're going to go in
here and wanna spawn uh some pigs and
want a lot of pigs so and we're also
going to want some trail mix so that
these pigs are fed and we're going to
sigma and this works just like the TT TT
MP on Shorty and the TTM fede launcher
where you just suck up pigs and it adds
them the side we look pretty awesome
look how good that looks so good and you
shoot them out and they send out neon
pigs it will nyan cat and then nvm bigs
and they have a little song and at the
rainbow farts and beautiful and it's a
really cool now they are very dangerous
so as I said before watch I wanna shoot
them and you really just make it rain
down I'm creative so there so that
everything for this model 'it and all
trail mix up back there for this mod i
hope you all enjoyed this video um
yeah i preciate covered everything yet
and if you did leave a like comment just
leave a like comment and stuff so I know
if to do more of these for all you
people who've been to my channel before
and if you're new to my channel I really
appreciate it subscribe and if you
enjoyed it so i will be gone with that I
hope you all love dish good drop and
good